I'm Peter schlosser I'm the associate
director and director of research at the
u.s. Institute here at Columbia
University it's a great pleasure to
welcome you to the event data management
and federal funding what researchers
need to know we have an introduction of
the topic by three speakers in a panel
for and I will introduce the speakers at
the beginning or three of them they will
speak about 15 to 20 minutes each after
their opening remarks we will have
plenty opportunity for questions and
answers all questions from the from your
audience we also have some written
questions I think the panelists have
seen them if they are not yet addressed
during your remarks I will try to feed
them in to the questions that we get
from the audience I think we are going
in the following order first we will
hear from a Victoria study who is an
assistant professor of statistics here
at Columbia University she serves as a
member of the National Science
Foundation's Advisory Committee for
cyber infrastructure she is one of the
creators of sparse lab a collaborative
platform for reproducible computational
research and has developed a new
licensing structure for computational
research called a reproducible research
standard she is currently working on the
NSF funded project policy designed for
preferred usability and data sharing in
computational science she cultured
co-chaired a working group on
communications and virtual organizations
for NSF's office of cyber infrastructure
Task Force on grain challenged
communities she's a science common
fellows a nominated member of the Sigma
Chi scientific research society she also
serves on the advisory board for heck
and y dot org and is currently serving
on the Columbia Senate IT committee
after that we will hear from Seyi
shatori with the associate dean for
teach for library digital programs and
watson director of
digital research and curation center at
the Sheraton libraries of John Hopkins
University he's also the director of
operations for the Institute of data
intensive engineering and science based
at Johns Hopkins and the principal
investigator for the data Conservancy
one of the awards to NSF data net
program say it is senior presidential
fellow with the Council on library and
information resources and a member of
the icpsr Council duros baseboard the
digital library Federation Advisory
Committee and the library of conquest
national digital stewardship allowance
coordinating committee after Saeed has
finished his remarks we will hear from
casting Lena Keston is a senior research
scientist at the lamont-doherty Earth
Observatory at Columbia University she's
also director of the integrated earth
data applications research group castine
has led the development of data models
for sample based observations and the
design of interactive web-based towards
for data search retrieval and synthesis
she has worked closely with the science
community developing standards for data
documentation and reported cast in his
vice chair of the Chi informatik
informatics division for a geological
society of america is a member of the
executive committee of the husn space
science information focus group and a
member of the scientific program
committee of the european geosciences
unit union she's also a member of the
unit data policy committee and is on the
board of the NASA c-deck long-term
activity
okay wonderful it's a real pleasure to
be here and thank you for the
introduction Cathy asked me to talk
about data management and sharing
policies in a federal agency
specifically NSF and I National Science
Foundation and National Institutes for
health I work for an either so I've been
involved in some discussions and I have
no inside information but I can talk to
you about what my impressions are from a
personal personal standpoint so the
first thing I wanted to mention is the
backdrop that my senses for policymakers
and other people and why policy is
actually changing so I'm sure everybody
in this room is aware that the impact of
technology on how we conduct university
research today has been extremely
profound and is now actually reaching
vary widely in too many different
departments and affecting the core of
how we do our research and this it takes
place not just in in increases in
computational power and use in the
research and increases in data what many
people are calling the data deluge but
also in terms of how we communicate in
the use of the Internet to distributed
and disseminate our findings so just
very quickly just so I've been I think
I've been corrected even on the first
one that three terabytes a year of
genome sequence data being produced as
far too low and so on so we're producing
enormous amounts of data even LHC so the
CMS the CMS project at LHC 300 events
per second when the reading it
eventually accumulates to 780 terabytes
a year and they're talking about how do
we share this and how do we make this
open this enormous amounts of data and
the fact that these datasets are
becoming openly available is just
symptomatic of the type of research that
we can do and how research is changing
and this he has profound effects on how
in SF and NIH are thinking about the way
that they treat research in the width of
policies that build around research and
research funding so not only in terms of
the data deluge but we also have it
fairly new over the last 20 years
massive simulations of the
complete evolution of a physical system
where we can rerun this very parameter
systematically and learn about the world
in new ways so both of these are
fundamentally impacting the policy
landscape for researchers and especially
I'll make one point that I think when
people talk about data and then the data
deluge is often lost and I think it's it
shouldn't be lost is the importance of
software anytime you have data you have
code that somehow put it there so
there's always code symptomatically
linked with data and should be always
included in the discussion and it's not
just that data operates through code and
software and this is how you access it
and develop the data it's also the case
and this is really speaking as a
statistician that many deep intellectual
contributions are now actually embedded
in software like how do we process or
extract findings on from these huge data
set so whenever we're talking about data
in my opinion we're also having a
discussion about code and we want to
just bear that in mind as we go forward
okay also very quickly just to support
this point one of our flagship journals
a journal of the american statistical
association i looked at how many of
their publications included a
computational component going back to
nineteen ninety-six and then if they did
include a computational component could
I actually get access to that code and
understand how that code actually
operated on the data to produce the
results that were being published and
you can see in 1996 I go from or the
journal goes from a little under half
are actually computational articles to
today we're solidly if you're publishing
in this journal you're publishing
computational work I mean there may be
mathematics and proofs in there but
there at some point even if it's just an
example you have computational
components that are actually being
published nobody in 1996 talked about
where I could get the code to try and
understand how these results were
derived like beyond the description in
the paper in 2011 21 percent are telling
me where i can download their package
are talking about the software itself so
much better but still very very low
especially when you remember that the
way that we're communicating these
results in the paper
wasn't designed with software in mind
and much of the information you would
need to replicate this work or
understand the work and build on it is
in the software not in the paper ok so
the framing behind all this and these
policy discussions is how science is
changing based on these changes due to
technology and we have very old ideas
about what science is that I presume
that everyone here is familiar with but
commonly called the first branch of the
scientific method going back to the
Greeks is our deductive reasoning and
falling into this this category is
mathematics or logic where really we
have a self-contained deductive system
then the second branch is the empirical
branch where we can't apply these same
rules for discerning what a scientific
fact is we had to come up with new rules
and so now we have things like
statistical analysis of controlled
experiments we have other machinery that
I'll talk about in a moment about how we
actually derive scientific knowledge
from empirical work lots of discussion
over the last few years you can see it
in keynotes and policy discussions
Society meetings are we actually
developing a third branch of the
scientific method with all the
simulation work that we're doing with
the data deluge and data-driven science
if so what are the standards this photo
here is my advisor David Donahoe and he
and I and others have argued that if
really want the computational work is
going to be elevated to a third branch
of the scientific method will need to
really have some clear thinking about
what those standards are that that would
make a computational result really a
scientific fact okay this thinking has
taken place on the first and second
branch of the scientific method with the
deductive branch you are not publishing
a sign of mathematical result without a
clear proof on how you actually got to
that result and if you try to publish
this without the proof all these
mathematicians everyone knows what the
standards are and you wouldn't be able
to publish the work there's similar
standards and these are
standards of transparency a core similar
standards evolved for the empirical
branch where there's an entire machinery
of hypothesis testing very structured
methods sections and how you would
communicate the work and communication
of protocols and so on so other people
can actually replicate the work and see
what you did computational science we're
still thinking about this this is new
it's not hundreds of years old like the
other branches we're thinking about what
are our standards to allow other people
to replicate the work what are our
standards for rooting out error really
what science is truly about a core and
how do we how do we create these
standards and how do we promulgate them
so this is really what's sort of turning
around in my opinion in the background
of a lot of these policy debates okay so
how does policy play into this given
this entire landscape for the discussion
so for funding agencies there are grant
requirements about Disco's disclosure of
cloak code and disclosure of data and
I'll just take a moment to because I
don't want you to read this tiny text
I'll just take a moment to explain it
okay so NSF grant guidelines and this
goes way back so I extracted this from
2005 grant guidelines and this is not
new in 2005 so it's been around a while
NSF expects investigators to share with
other researchers or no more than
incremental costs and within a
reasonable time the data right samples
physical clutch with other supporting
materials created or gathered in the
course of the work it also encourages
grantees to share software and
inventions or otherwise act to make the
innovations they embody widely useful
and usable okay so this is clearly a
response to the fact that lots of
science is happening on a computer and
in order to understand what people have
done when they've used a computer to
generate results I submit to you that we
need to get access to code we need to
get access to the data to verify the
work the majority of what's being
published today is not verified and
there are deep ramifications to this
that I'll get to in a moment ok and I'll
talk about in more detail the NSF peer
reviewed data management plan and how
this came about as something of a
response to both the guidelines and also
to the landscape
that I outlined okay NIH NIH is a little
ahead of NSF in terms of openness in
2003 these are also grant guidelines for
the further really big over five hundred
thousand dollar grant the NIH endorses
the sharing of final research data so
this isn't just sharing the publication
to serve these and other important
scientifical the NIH expects and
supports the timely release and sharing
the final research data from NIH
supported studies for use by other
researchers okay this is in our grant
guidelines rarely does it happen people
do the computational work and it's
difficult to lay hands on the data that
they use with many notable exceptions
but generally speaking it's difficult
even more difficult as I showed you with
my Jasso example earlier to get your
hands on the code the actual steps that
the researcher went through to generate
these computational results that are
published we're supposed to believe
right okay the NSF data management plan
so that came about in January this
year's people are probably familiar with
proposals submitted or do on January
18th or after must include a
supplementary document of no more than
two pages labeled data management plan
difficult to be any more vague than that
this this supplementary document should
describe how the proposal will conform
to NSF policy whatever that is right on
the dissemination and sharing of
research results so I believe the policy
that they're referring to is what I just
elucidated with the sharing of software
and sharing of data in the grant
guidelines this is really what they're
telling you about data management plans
so I think this so my impression is that
this is left perfect purposefully vague
there's a very close relationship
between how and SF thinks and how the
research community and the actual
researchers think and I think NSF is
rightly wary of being too far ahead of
where researchers are so there's this
symbiotic relationship where one will
sort of push another if you think about
what it takes if you've ever done
computational work and you think about
what it takes to share the code and the
data that you use to
your work it's a non-trivial problem
right for a number of reasons that
probably are popping into your head and
some of those reasons probably pertain
to the type of data and the field that
you're in and are very domain-specific
so it's difficult for NSF to just come
down in a heavy-handed way and say you
have to share a code and data I mean
that's all so vague what does that mean
is it dated from your raw gather data
that then you filter is this data that's
come from other sources and what's the
provenance where do I share it NSF
hasn't told me where there's a site
where i can and am I expected to put
that on my webpage and what about the
code like how much and does the guy on
the street have to be able to run my
code like what kind of code quality are
we talking about here is it just other
research so there's a lot of these
questions that I think there's not a
single answer that really applies to
everyone doing computational research
aside from the fact that the
computational research itself is
changing and how we do it so this is
this is purposefully vague and NSF
doesn't say anything like we need to see
that you're going to be open with the
data the idea here is there just
fact-finding at this point they want to
see what researchers write down where
the bottlenecks are where what the
thinking is and in a way you can gather
a fair amount of information about data
sharing practices and how researchers
view data sharing and what the problems
might actually be just from asking for
these two pages so at this stage my
understanding is in some sense it
doesn't really matter what your even you
can write that you can't share the data
or the data are you know always been
open and there's no problem um there
isn't really any standards at NSF is
expecting of the researchers that's my
impression so that you know like I said
I'm just a person so I didn't smell my
policy but but that's what that's what I
think and I think that SF actually has a
wonderful opportunity here for collating
the information that comes in on these
data management plans and find out where
what's going on in the research
community I think this is not cheap
right for people to share code and share
data
and there may be hesitation about costs
and what it would take to underwrite
this and you know if people talk about
what it costs and put that information
into their grant applications they can
actually start to get a handle on this
so I think this can be very valuable at
this point I'm not aware of it having
you know of there being any NSF wide
standards about what should be in there
fact I know there or not so um so that's
that's the the overview of the data
management plan it may be a step forward
towards something more but right now
it's not it's just something that comes
up it is peer reviewed so it is
something that the NSF is allowing to
devolve to the communities to evaluate
and and come up with their own standards
and in my opinion that's exactly right i
don't really have a choice okay so a
little bit more so the data management
plan no requirements or directives
regarding i did open it specifically as
i was saying but they do have on their
faq page investigators are expected to
share with other researchers at northern
cross all there so on and so on grantees
are expected to encourage and facilitate
such sharing privilege of confidential
information should be release only in a
form that protects the privacy of
individuals and subjects involved it
reads a lot like the grant guidelines
right and this is on their faq page so
it looks like a lot of the thinking is
coming from how do we enforce these
grant guidelines that really up to now
have not been enforceable well let's see
what people say through um data
management plans okay am i required to
deposit my date in a public database
what constitutes reasonable data
management access will be determined by
the community of interest not by NSF at
all through the process of peer review
and program management in many cases
these standards already exist but are
likely to evolve as new technologies and
resources become available so it's open
and it's up to the community so NSF is
really taking a step back okay so NIH is
facing a different set of issues NIH has
been pushed a little bit I don't know if
people have followed in the news there
were clinical trials at Duke that were
has since been terminated and now this
has
launched this entire inquiry into what
happened in this case so I'm going to
run down some very high level details of
the case and argue to you that this is
actually a failure of data sharing and a
failure of code sharing particularly the
code sharing in this case so there were
two research while a group of
researchers on Nevins and podia Duke and
they publish highly acclaimed papers
2006-2007 they published in Nature
Medicine New England Journal of Medicine
lancet oncology until on their papers
won't awards as well so what they were
doing is they were finding evidence that
they could use your genomic data to
tailor what type of cancer drug would
work best for you so this is one of the
Holy Grails of medicine and so this
gathered a lot of attention there were
several researchers at the MD Anderson
Cancer Research Center at UT Austin who
of course became aware of these results
and found them very exciting and
compelling and just wanted to learn
about the technologies and replicate the
work so they said about actually trying
to come up with the same results that
had been published in all these
different journals so by the way all
these papers that that one these were
this one of all the sense has been
retracted and more that have come from
this group so problems started right
away when they started trying to take
the data so it's also key to note that
this is happening in the genome
sequencing community where some of the
data has been made public and there is a
history of the data being available and
coons wang and beggarly and the other
folks at UT Austin were able to get some
of the data that way and be able to
replicate some or at least try to
replicate some of the work and they
found lots of problems they found issues
like columns were mislabeled there were
genes in the test category that didn't
show up in training category that were
supposed to be compared there were there
seemed to be off by one misalignment
between train and tests so the genes had
sort of it it's like an Excel to our
problem and you need to take care of
your headers sort of thing those are
very simple mistakes that there's not
really any coherent way that that could
have been caught in peer review right so
this is something where it's
really in the code that they're using or
maybe it's in what the postdocs are
doing I don't know but but if you've
ever done this type of computational
work these are simple things to do right
okay so based on the work as MD Anderson
folks were doing there what they call
forensic bioinformatics trying to sort
of back solve and get the results that
had been published clinical trials were
actually initiated in 2007 Duke and
there was one at Moffitt at 2008 January
2010 it Duke patients were actually
allocated to treatment and control
groups based on this flawed
computational work and actually were
given drugs remember we had flipped
labels on the drugs and things like that
and there were serious problems in the
work it's another story about the
scientific communication and how they
tried to make this and the Anderson
folks tried to make this more widely
known but in the interest of time I
won't go into it here but in july of
last year 33 prominent biostatisticians
wrote two of our messes National Cancer
Institute Director urging suspension of
the trials examination of standards of
review including issues of
reproducibility that I've been bringing
up throughout the talk September 2010 so
late last year Institute of Medicine
committee was formed review of omics
based tests for predicting patient
outcomes in clinical trials so it's a
serious enough issue where the committee
has now been formed to look at standards
for clinical trials particularly when
the work that's being done is deeply
computational the way these were and how
do we verify this work and how do we
understand standards where we can
actually feel safe about starting a
clinical trial and you know actually
giving drugs to treatment people 2010
pody resins clinical trials are
terminated the follow up is now there
are a number of lawsuits that have been
launched by patients or families of
patients who have since died who were in
the clinical trials just talking about
you know just trying to understand what
happened and how this could actually
have gotten to this stage so this is
something this is one issue NIH is
dealing weather of course it's a massive
organization dealing with many s
but the clinical trials issue has now
come up and it's being pushed by this
lack of reproducibility in the
computational science that was
underlying the initiation of clinical
trials okay so I won't read this one to
you but the letter d'ivoire miss from
the biostatisticians what I'll point out
to you is the data should be
sufficiently documented for Providence
to be accessed to be assessed the
computer code used to predict which
drugs are suitable for particular
patients must be made available to allow
an independent group of expert genomic
data analyses and analysts to assess its
validity and reproducibility using the
data supplied you wouldn't think an
outsider looking into how we do science
you wouldn't think that that's missing
but it's missing we just couldn't get
that information in the Duke case so now
the advise statisticians are calling for
greater clarity and transparency in the
computational work that's published at
least the ones that are moving towards
clinical trials okay so there's our
Institute of Medicine that's the review
of omics based tests for predicting
patient outcomes they're having I think
they've had seven meetings so far and
they've heard from Duke and kind of
moving towards updating this policy at
the NIH level okay very briefly I'll
just finish up with touching on what
Congress is doing so one thing I think
that we forget about is computational
researchers is but with the federal
funding Congress has a fair amount to
say about things that we do so in early
this year i think in january America
COMPETES that act was reauthorized and
there's two things I wanted to point out
to you that are very interesting in this
act that have bearing on our discussion
today so the first one is section 103
interagency public access committee
coordinate federal science agency
research policies related to
dissemination and long-term stewardship
of the results of unclassified research
now what's interesting is what I
italicize here including digital data so
now the data discussion is actually in
legislation and and there's talk about
well how do we share this how do we
curate this how do we make it available
for a long amount of time and they're
also talking about peer-reviewed
scholarly publications and so on section
104 i mentioned mandates at the office
of science technology policy in the
white
develops policies for the management and
use of federal scientific collections to
improve the quality organization access
including online access and long-term
preservation of such collections so they
don't specifically mention data there
but they are cognizant of the fact that
we are moving online and we need to be
able to access digital and electronic
works and with section 103 this should
include data and I'm hoping that the
discussion of code is subsumed in the
discussion of data as well as as you as
I mentioned earlier I think it's a
mistake to talk about data in isolation
okay Oh actually in the interest of time
I'll skip by doll act but this certainly
has many intellectual property
ramifications as we share code and with
shared data were also pulled by
incentive structures that have been in
place since 1980 from the bayh-dole Act
which of course gave us our tech
transfer offices and patent and shifted
patenting rights to the institution for
work developed at the institution and
what I will point out is that the
bayh-dole Act notice it was passed in
nineteen eighty nobody had any idea of
what was going to happen with computers
and with science and with the Internet
at that point they were thinking about a
wholly different world and so now with
software patenting by doll has a very
deep impact on what we do today as
computational scientists not necessarily
computer scientists are not necessarily
people in pharma but anytime you're
using code and you want to share it now
there's a bayh-dole implications about
what you're doing at least you would
want to think through okay so a blizzard
of words just to mention that these
issues and reproducibility and data and
code sharing that are being picked up at
the policy level at NSF level at NIH
level in the White House and Congress
there's also an emergent grassroots
level happening across the scientific
landscape I'll very quickly point out
that you can see applied mathematics
there you can see geosciences there you
can see bioinformatics there siam
there's all sorts of discussion
happening often independently there's
not a lot of communication about this
necessarily between the different field
but they're becoming very aware that
these are issues that in their fields
they need to deal with okay so I'll stop
there in the interest on I put up
few references they're all available on
my website so on the slides for this
talker also up on my website as well if
you're interested so I'll turn it over
to
begin by thanking Catherine for the
invitation and thanking Victoria for
framing conversations oh well thank you
for doing that I'm going to talk about
an effort that you heard about in my
introduction called the data Conservancy
which is one of the current awards
through the NSF data net program it's a
large-scale data infrastructure
development effort and I'd like to talk
in particular about how it's resulted in
a service at Johns Hopkins that's
focused in particular on the NSF data
management requirement briefly about the
data Conservancy this is a statement
that we've been using to describe it at
a very high level there are three
particular points I'd like to make about
data Conservancy first is that word
blueprint and actually the letter in
front of it a it's not the blueprint
it's a blueprint for for data curation
infrastructure and my blueprint I
basically mean hardware software people
and the policy framework that you can
use to actually cure a data from
different sources and different domains
and and that's really the second major
point about data Conservancy that I'd
like to make is from the very inception
of this effort we had been looking at
data from different disciplines so in in
Victoria slides you saw references to
the Sloan Digital Sky Survey that's
actually one of the large datasets that
we've been dealing with we have
agreement with the Astrophysical
research consortium which is the legal
entity that speaks on behalf of that
data to curate those datasets and we
have brought in the data from that
project and it is very large it's
actually remarkably diverse as well
we've also dealt with data from an
individual investigator named Bruce
Marsh at Johns Hopkins he's an igneous
petrology 'used who's been going to the
Dry Valleys in Antarctica every other
year for about 20 or 25 years and
collecting a very diverse range of
different kinds of data and we also have
some data from the biodiversity
community in the form of oceanographic
and salinity readings in the Chesapeake
Bay now we picked these three different
types very deliberately not only to look
across different disciplines
but also across different data types
different community practices and
different instruments so if you think
about the sloan project it's this 15
year very well funded large community
effort using one instrument so that that
has some profound implications for how
people actually work together and
generate data now you don't just get to
use the sloan telescope whenever you
wish you actually have to go through
some very formal process for applying
and i suspect that if you showed up and
basically said i'm not going to use
community standards and i don't care
what anyone else can do with my data you
probably wouldn't be very successful in
getting access to the telescope on the
other hand the Dry Valleys project is is
really an individual it's it's Bruce
Marsh as a p.i that has trained
generation at this point maybe two
generations of scientists and in many
ways I like to joke that Bruce's the
instrument for that particular project I
know he uses a lot of real instruments
but there's a lot of knowledge trapped
in Bruce's head tacit knowledge that
we've been trying to extract quite
frankly in order to curate his data some
of it is easy to extract some of it not
so easy so we're trying to look across
these different disciplines and
different practices to build an
infrastructure that's very robust and
very flexible and then the third key
point that I'd like to mention is that
word preserve we think preservation is a
really critical aspect of data curation
and I'll talk a little bit more about
that but the key takeaway for you is
that we believe preparing data and
building an infrastructure and a
framework for preservation actually
fosters a lot of reuse of data a lot of
sharing and I'd like to believe actually
transparency and reproducibility now in
that spirit I want to share this slide
and I won't spend a whole lot of time on
it but I do think it's important to draw
this distinction between archiving
preservation and curation we sometimes
use the terms interchangeably and we
think of them very differently in the
data Conservancy context and this is a
very deliberate representation from the
bottom of the stack coming
up to the top of that stack and
archiving for us is very much the
actions to support long-term data
protection these are things like storage
backup fixity checking media migration
and then if you come up the stack you
have preservation which is actually the
policy and the actions to ensure the
long-term access and I note that in the
data realm five years could be an
eternity in some ways and sharing in an
example of that is of course format
migration and then at the top of the
stack is that curation term which we use
to connote that it's adding value to
foster that you reuse and unanticipated
use and in some cases is actually
unanticipated used by the same
investigator you end up talking to pis
and researchers who say i can't even use
my own data from five years ago much
less somebody else so it really is not
just a problem about how you share with
others in some sense it's how you share
with yourself into the future and i'll
talk a little bit about some
capabilities that we think are at the
curation layer i think a good definition
of preservation comes from one of my
colleagues and daddy conservancies ruth
door and she basically said preservation
is about creating enough context and
representation information and fixity
and metadata and so on so that someone
other than the original data producer
can interpret and use the data if you
have to keep going back to the bruce
marshes of the world you can imagine
that's not a long-term solution we have
to get to the point where someone can
actually use the data without contacting
the original producer either human or
machine this slide shows the
architecture for the data Conservancy on
the right that's the block diagram I'm
not going to go into all of the elements
I'll just talk about one and it's
mapping to the OAS OA is sorry reference
model or the functional entities of that
particular reference model and this very
much reinforces this perception or i
should say principle on our part
thinking about archiving and
preservation as guidelines for how we
develop our infrastructure not as a goal
into itself but actually as
the means to support the kind of
curation activities that we think
ultimately will be very important if
we're to do new and interesting things
with data so you can see that by the
color coding that there's basically a
mapping of our architecture to this
framework and we've been using this in
many ways as our initial set of
requirements and software development
strategies one particular aspect that
I'd like to focus on in this block
diagram is the so-called feature
extraction framework when we've been
working with these different kinds of
data we started with the data model from
a European project called planets I
think it's fair to say it's primarily
preservation focused but what we learned
very quickly is that if you're dealing
with different disciplines data models
get pushed around quite a bit it's very
hard to imagine to come up with one data
model that will be extensible enough for
lots of different disciplines we seem to
be drifting migrating evolving however
you want to think about it to the idea
of supporting multiple data models
rather than trying to take one and
stretch it too far we were beginning to
think that instead we should just accept
that there will be multiple data models
and that begs the question then how are
you actually going to discover anything
if you're trying to support different
data models the approach we've been
taking is through the so-called feature
extraction framework it's really a
two-step process so if you have some
sort of format registry in place and you
can assert that this is this particular
kind of format and these are its salient
properties then you can extract useful
information based on that format
registry assertion a simple example
could be spreadsheets where you have
columns of rows it's tabular data you
mean you may know you may assert that
its temperature data for example or you
can extract things from tiff headers
things of that nature Victorio talked
about science being in the software i
think that that's absolutely correct in
some sense what we're trying to think
about is can cure a shin be in the
software as well I think this has very
profound implications for things like
metadata treatment we cannot scale
enough I can't say this enough we can't
scale up enough to produce metadata
annually I just don't believe that we
don't have enough people we don't have
enough expertise we don't have enough
time we're going to have to use machines
in some way to augment the kind of
processes we've been typically using for
document based repositories and I think
the feature extraction framework is very
important in this particular context
what can you do automatically across
different kinds of data data different
kinds of data model to make assertions
about what the metadata might be or what
query capabilities you might want to
build on those datasets so the data
conservancies just finished its second
year at the end of July we just started
our third while we were working
throughout the second year as Victoria
mentioned NSF's new data management plan
requirement went live in January 2011
it's not surprising perhaps that a lot
of pis and Hopkins approach to their
department chairs or their Dean's and
said we need help with data management
plans and we hear the library has some
large award to build data curation
infrastructure what can they do for us
to be honest when we started the data
Conservancy of course we didn't know
this data management plan would become
live and even in the midst of working on
data Conservancy we had planned for a
much later deployment in some sense we
thought there was more work to be done
more research to take place but it's
very difficult to turn around and tell
your faculty researchers and your Dean's
and chairs well just know we'll do it
later so in essence we moved very
quickly I think very aggressively to
take the initial lessons from data
Conservancy and build an actual service
and this service includes some initial
infrastructure where you can deposit
your data we would keep it there to
preserve it for the long term and
ultimately build these kinds of
capabilities like the feature extraction
framework that I described the j2
administration the Johns Hopkins
administration basically came forward
and said we'd like to work together to
do this and I think this is a really
important point to make the service that
we've developed is run by the libraries
but we don't think of it as a library
service this is part of the research
support structure at Johns Hopkins so
there are research compliance dimensions
there are reducing the burden on p
eyes there's producing better data
management plans there's avoiding the
kinds of things that you heard about
that happened at Duke so it's come
together into this larger framework of
how do you support researchers at a
research institution and how do you do
so in a way that reduces the burden yet
also produces better results both in
terms of the specific plan and then
actually the implementation of those
plans so I'm glad to say that the
administration is actually stepped
forward and said okay we need to fund
this independently of the NSF award so
this service that's being run now does
not take advantage of any of the funding
that we have through NSF it's being
funded completely through the university
itself now I should point out there two
stages to this particular service one is
prior to the proposal being submitted
when people get help putting together
these two page plans that's being paid
for by the university directly so there
are certain staff that we've hired who
work with the pis directly and say we
can help you with with putting this plan
together that does not incur any costs
of the pis at all and anyone can use
that particular service post award we
have a decision point basically which is
do you wish to use this particular
archive that we built do you wish to use
something else or do you not even need
an archive so in cases where they intend
to use the Jeju archive we do ask them
to include a line item in their budgets
for the for the grants themselves so
that's basically the path we've taken
its these two stages pre-proposal
consultations are free paid for directly
by the institution post award it's part
of the proposal budget and then of
course we'd have to work out wonderful
things like retention schedules and
selection criteria and so on these are
some URLs that you can look at to get
more context about this particular
service the first one basically talks
about the process we went through well
very broadly speaking we just looked at
supply and demand quite frankly as I'd
mentioned we've been working with the
research administration at Hopkins so we
were able to get access
to the pis of NSF proposals for the past
five years we ran a survey with them and
ask them what kind of day do you produce
how much what are you doing with it now
where is it things of that nature made
forecasts estimates based on how much
data we thought people might need to put
into the archive and then on our side we
used experience that we have with data
like Sloan or dry valleys and said it
takes about this much time we think to
do these particular sets of activities
put all that together and came up with
the financial model the details of the
service itself are described in that
second URL it actually has a lot of
information about good data management
practices as well but if you look at
that you can see what services are
available and what process you have to
go through then the last thing I want to
say is these are early days we are still
refining all aspects of the service so I
don't want to stand up here and pretend
like it's done but i can tell you we're
really in the thick of it right now and
it's it's an interesting experience so
with that I'll turn it over to Kirsten
thank you as such it just said they in
the process of learning and I think what
my contribution here is to actually give
experiences of a long learning process
we the data a facility that i'm heading
actually has more than 10 years of
experiences in providing data services
for a special community and i am i will
make the point that there is a huge
benefit of having disciplinary
repositories and data services that can
actually support the science and that's
why I i called my presentation bringing
carrots to the table because i think
that's important things like the data
management plan our sticks in some way
to the investigator to share their data
but we need to engage the communities
and make them really want to share their
data because there are benefits to it
and those are the carrots that
preliminary data facility can provide
lots of things were mentioned already
with respect to the need for data
sharing the growth of the data the
digital information that's out there so
I don't need to say much about it but I
always like this quote from the report
on science and five dimensions saying
that the power of digital information to
catalyze progress is limited only by the
power of the human mind lots of
discussions have gone on to really take
advantage of the digital information and
the new capabilities out there and this
has happened on an international basis
for example the report by the
organization of Economic Cooperation and
Development on sharing of research data
has triggered a lot of the then more
national efforts to implement
infrastructures so this has led to the
data management plan at the NSF and
actually i think the and the office here
of scholarly communication invited an
NSF program manager and she couldn't
make it but she did send me a couple of
slides to show NSF's point and i'm
putting this particular slide up here in
that it emphasizes the the trigger for
the data management plans are the
changes that are needed to address the
needs for modern data-driven science and
this phrase that victoria already
mentioned this avoids a
one-size-fits-all approach to data
sharing you two differences between
disciplines is critical for me it there
are big differences in each community
has may or may not have their own
standards their own ways to deal with
data and that's what we need to address
again this was also up there already
what constitutes reasonable data
management and access will be determined
by the community of interest so the
process of peer review and program
management and so there are standards in
a particular commune
of interest that can drive or should
drive the way data is handed now this is
again a slide provided by the science
foundation about all the different
pieces that should be included in the
data management plan such as you know
standards that will be used for data and
metadata the policies for excess of
plans for archiving the data and so on
and each investigator starts asking
where what are these standards what are
the policies what archives are
appropriate for me and this is I think
were again the Disciplinary data
archives can help so CEO is standing for
community of interest community of
interest data collections in my view can
maximize the utility of data for science
and education and that's the carer that
we're putting out there how does that
happen well a data center that has
disciplinary expertise can ensure data
quality based on that expertise by
making sure the data is properly
formatted is documented right performing
Quality Assurance quality control on the
data and then provide interfaces to
these data that are science driven that
allow scientists to discover the data
they looking for that they can access
them in formats that are useful for the
tools they're using in their research
and so on and link them to specific
software to analysis tools and so on
these and these data collections
actually harmonize data because we do a
certain manipulation of metadata to make
sure that the data is homogeneous in the
description in their quality and so on
and we integrated so there is a real
synthesis that people can take advantage
of we can implement community specific
policies such as access restrictions
they very often determined within the
community how many years can data stay
with restricted access in a data
repository and so on we can provide peer
review if needed and an important point
also
community of interest data collection
can represent the interests of that
community to other data stakeholders and
that could be funding agencies when they
trying to cut the funding for the
facility or if they can put in on allow
you to end our line item for data
management into your proposal and so on
or this can be guided in some way by the
data repository the important really
important words I think for the relation
of a data facility with its user
communities a quality trust and utility
those are the three words that actually
capture I think what a relationship
should be like and I specifically point
to this article by gamble & Gobel on the
quality trust and utility of scientific
data on the web summarizing all the
right terms that are relevant and to to
add value to data and to make people
want to share their data so very briefly
I wanted to say what the data facility
does that and that we're operating at
Lomond it's a community-based data
facility and provides centralized access
to observational data within the earth
sciences marine terrestrial and from the
polar regions it's funded by the
National Science Foundation's were
cooperative agreement and this
cooperative agreement was established
only a year ago the actual data
activities stayed back into the early
1990s but based on the success the
community acceptance we were able to
make it to turn this into a facility
that has a longer term support now in a
much more stable support and it's
managed and operated at lamont-doherty
the two underlying data systems are the
marine Geoscience data system and the
geoinformatics for geochemistry programs
these are two very specialized data
collections they provide services for
the archiving for the preservation for
excess
to these data sets user support
education a lot of a lot of different
services and I don't want to go into
that because I'm sure there aren't that
many geoscientists in the audience are
actually interested in this the
motivation been between the motivation
underlying the initial establishing of
these data activities was really to
democratize the access to research
resources to ensure that data and any
information is broadly disseminated to
facilitate a more efficient use of
resources many of the data that I
actually collected in the earth sciences
on ships or in on expeditions going into
faraway countries and locations are very
expensive to generate and so these this
data and even samples need to be easily
accessible and need to be taken
advantage by a broader community the
verification of research results is
always one of the points and was brought
up in the reproducibility of actual data
reduction of computation earlier and the
most important I think is that we
provide new research opportunities and
this is actually been one of our big
successes that we can show the impact on
science that these data collections that
we've made available actually have
triggered new discoveries and new
insights in the sciences our core values
basically summarized our approaches that
we've we've taken i mean the reuse and
sharing of data are fundamental for the
Advancement of science the data
preservation and documentation I at the
heart of transformative cyber
infrastructure data acquired by public
funding should be publicly accessible
and science needs must guide the design
of the data systems so transferring that
into the approaches that we have taken I
think those have been the keys for our
success we have made data useful for
research and education people rely they
can rely on the
quality of the data collections because
we have performed rigorous Quality
Assurance quality control there is
comprehensive content because we have
proactively gathered data there are
interfaces for easy and scientifically
meaningful access to the data support of
data analysis and really important with
respect to the more evolving earth
systems and science and and
multidisciplinary approaches to
scientific questions is the integration
with other data within and across
disciplines that we are actually
facilitating we do a lot of community
support and the close relation to the
community has been one of the keys keys
to our success we have developed
standards for the data documentation we
provide the tools or templates or
tutorials for data submission training
education and outreach and another very
important aspect that hasn't quite come
up is the credit to the data
contributors which is one of the key
concerns in the science community so
just a few brief points about the
success success we have a huge user
community in the meantime and something
like in the order of seven terabytes
download per quarter now this is one of
my favorite slides that I've been
showing is a comment by a user actually
five years ago already they're talking
about one of the data collections and
the use for science saying that more
than just a time saver these databases
make it possible to address those both
global and regional questions that I
would otherwise never bother to attempt
the amount of time saved as such that
countless ideas cross from the realm of
the totally impractical for a busy
working scientist into the realm of easy
to squeeze into a spare half hour that's
the advantage of a real good data
management for science and as I
mentioned new science has been generated
even made it to the NSF
page at some point but we have hundreds
of citations in the scientific
literature from studies that have taken
advantage of these data databases at the
moment now we're actually focusing even
more on facilitating data submissions
and this is triggered by the data
management plans because we're
increasingly getting a data submitted by
investigators and we do have built a
data management plan to it and that what
we're also trying to do is to even
better ensure the credit for submitted
data through data publication so I'm
very briefly i'm going to show you these
new capabilities with the data
management plan tool it's actually been
very useful for the investigator so
using that because it's targeted at this
specific community so when people go
there they can select which data type
they will produce in their in their
study that they are proposing so in the
data management plan they can select a
specific data type will then be shown a
list of possible repositories that they
can select from they can already save
which is the access restriction
timeframe where these data be made
available right away or will it be
restricted for a certain amount of time
and so on and this tour then produces a
PDF that can go into the the proposal we
have this was launched in January two
thousand eleven at the time when the
data management plans became mandatory
and has so far been used for 153 data
management plans so that's quite
impressive and also for a large variety
of intended repositories so these aren't
used just by people who want to submit
to us but people who want to submit
anywhere and 20 repositories nationally
or even internationally an interesting
addition to this that we're working on
is a tool that actually then allows
people to
show compliance with what they promised
in their data management plans so when
they get their proposal funded and then
submit data to our repository the
information that they've provided in the
data management plan will be linked to
the data sets that they have submitted
and they can easily get to our system
call up an award number and get a report
from our systems which data sets have
been made available to our data facility
and that can go to NSF as part of an
annual report or as part of a final
report so last but not least is the data
publication this is something really
close to my heart I think this will
drive a lot of the the willingness to
share data when in the past data of them
not included in the publication and and
people have not and when they then send
it to a colleague or shared it through a
repository they basically don't get
credit for it and making data actually a
sizable entity that can then be
referenced in other people's
publications in your own publications is
a big advantage and there are many
efforts going on to basically provide
unique identification inside ability to
data sets we're doing it through an
effort core data site it's an
international consortium that provides
services by basically cataloging
metadata for data sets and registering
these data sets within the DOI system so
a data set has a DOI and can be sided
inside a publication that also has a DUI
so and we were only starting this this
is still in a beta version so I can't
give you any experiences on this but I
think it will really change and change a
lot of the address a lot of the concerns
of the science community another
advantage
it actually has is that some publishers
start to link to the data sets via these
data set do is we have an agreement
already with elsevier they show
basically the links to the publications
and to the in the publication's the
links to the data sets and it's
interesting I just wanted to put this in
what the impact can be data sharing can
increase your citation index and that's
really I think it's something that
researchers are going to be looking for
that's my last slide I'm not going to
get very deep into it what I wanted to
emphasize and this is a slide that was
just shown two weeks ago at a conference
in kyoto by our colleague meteor i
didn't walk from the pangea data system
it emphasizes that when it comes to data
preservation data curation data
publication there are many entities many
different capabilities that are needed
to and to really implement an
infrastructure that can take care of
this and there are the the Disciplinary
data facilities that reside here at the
data collection and processing
facilities that can provide the QA QC
there are definitely roles for the
libraries to provide the cataloging
services the DOI registries there are
the long-term archives that have to play
a role in this so ultimately we are only
starting to build this infrastructure
about emphasizing that we need to work
together across the libraries or with
the institutions the research funding
organizations and the publishers
definitely to build a framework that
allows proper data access and data
archiving but again just as a last word
the Disciplinary component is for me
really relevant thank you
thank you to all the panelists for these
remarks that lay the foundation for the
discussion so we now enter into the
question-and-answer session and the
floor is open for your questions I see
there is a microphone so if you have a
question please use the microphone and
let us know your affiliation and post
your question please hi my name is
Seamus Thompson from biostatistics up
time so thanks for three terrific talks
I mean the issue verification is amazing
all of the talks were great just to add
another level of complexity and you were
saying they're different familiarity
with the different issues in different
disciplines I was at a conference last
week for the NIH rare disease consortium
for rare diseases and they were laying
out a plan for archiving the data and a
repository and they ran into a huge
problem because one of the participants
said well genomic data leaves the
individual completely identifiable and
therefore they argued that material that
was left in a repository could not be
used in another analysis for a different
person unless all patients were Rican
scented for that purpose which would
seem to perhaps kill the data sharing
which is the whole point and then
someone else went even further unstated
wrongly I believe that de-identified
data which did not have a genomic
component also required we free consent
and I furiously disputed this and said
it was an error but I'm wondering do you
have any observations about this issue
but it's something that the audience
should be aware of as something that
will come up so you should take
prospective steps at the very earliest
point really when you're consenting
patients in the first place to ensure
permission for
access and I wonder to the commentators
have any comments what's it take it I
can start there's a reason why we
started with astronomy data as
astronomers have told us 64 plus it has
no commercial value no privacy issues
and so on and I mean that's a facetious
comment but in all seriousness we did
want to start with unencumbered data we
another guiding principle I suppose we
have is it's best to start with an open
system and tighten the bolts later when
policy restrictions may arise I'm not an
expert in the identifying or
anonymization of data so let me just put
that out there but my understanding is
that is the technique that's used
already in many disciplines in terms of
trying to share the data so it's it's
certainly well worth thinking about that
I'm reminded of Victoria's comment that
things have changed a lot since we
started certain techniques so one idea
we've been exploring in this particular
realm it's not directly related but I
think it's relevant is a concept of data
fuzzing or deliberately obfuscating the
data so the case that we came up with
was apparently the North Slope of Alaska
people built ice roads they basically
just build channels out of lakes they
freeze and they become roads that you
can drive on and one of the big concerns
is getting too close to a polar bear den
because for obvious reasons some people
don't do nice things to polar bears I
suppose so there are people who have
data about where they think polar bears
are located but they don't want to share
that data in an open manner yet they
also want to protect the polar bears so
the idea that we put forward we actually
built I think a pretty clever
proof-of-concept about this is to
basically build some sort of arbitrary
region around where that polar bear
might be so when you're designing the
ice road you just avoid that region but
you don't get information about where
the polar bear is
larly and you can do the same thing with
its food sources and things like that so
I think that's the kind of technique
will have to use as we move forward but
I I don't have a full answer for your
your point I just wanted to agree with
everything so you just saying
confidentiality is certainly probably
it's the biggest issue when it comes to
sharing of data or the biggest stumbling
block having said that it's a for all
the data that can be shared as data
scientists it's a tranche right and so
it would be a shame the entire debate
was derailed because of confidentiality
concerns about certain particular domain
specific data having said that it just I
think this question really shows how
quickly things are changing in the sense
that it does sound like as the as at the
end of the question he said it looks
like our agreements that we're making
with patients who do consent to have
their data shared just haven't caught up
to the fact that sharing is wider than
we might have thought ten years ago or
20 years ago when data were used in a
study and that was it right and so that
looks like something with the IRB can
work with another sort of standards
bodies can work with an update and then
I absolutely agree that ID anonymization
this is also something where technology
is changing very quickly and it does
look like for data that do have privacy
concerns that extra steps need certainly
need to be taken there but this is
something where you know I'm calm I'm
optimistic that that we can surmount
these and that new technologies will
come on to do it having said that I
think that things like you know even
some small clinical trials data for sale
rare diseases I have trouble imagining a
situation where that's fully and openly
shared even if they've taken off names I
mean it's still very easy to identify
these folks particularly as more and
more data sets come online and it's
easier to sort of pin them together and
understand who's in them just based on
cross-referencing for example so that's
one of the challenges for open data but
but you know putting data together just
also makes the
lancia more rich that we can analyze but
ok you go go ahead if you want to yeah
just let me add one more thing that
actually builds on something both
Kirsten and Victoria said that we need
to think about the communities practices
and what their norms are and and I think
that in in some cases we also need to
think about levels of service so you may
be able to provide full access to
certain data and you may not be able to
but that's that's all right and we
encountered a mathematician that Hopkins
who told me that his data management
plan is one line I do not generate any
data so that may be the edge case but
the reality is that in some cases your
data management plan may explicitly
state you're not sharing the data and
the example Victoria gave is very good
one so it's very much consistent with
the NSF view that this is not one size
that's all but in cases where we can
share the data especially when we
typically have and I think that could be
huge gain say it's a comment just we got
a thought in my mind that I actually
universe was pondering throughout my
career and that that also has two links
to what the casting said at the end in
terms of citing data I think one of the
barriers that we have is that those who
produce data compared to those who say I
don't produce data feel that by being
asked to release them pretty much in
real time a lot of the projects and I'm
involved we have to release some of our
data real time gives actually an
advantage to those who are not
collecting data and some of my
colleagues you know use the name the
data scavengers I wouldn't go that far
but but clearly there is a there is an a
an element that citing data in databases
I think goes a good step in the right
direction but sitting on a lot of
promotion committees and other
you know appointment committees etc
reading dossiers I can guarantee you in
today's academic landscape that is
discounted you will not get the same
kind of recognition or your promotion
portfolio will not be seen as strong if
you have data citations compared to
citations that deal with the
interpretation and synthesis and I think
there is intrinsically built into our
system a structural problem that has to
be solved for those who are producing a
lot of data and share them immediately
so that they are not intrinsically
penalized by our systems of casting I
was wondering what what kind of thoughts
you have to death this is again an issue
that will evolve and will change you
know because this is only starting to to
happen and the recognition of you know
proper data management proper sharing
has in those last five years since you
know efforts have been pushed and and
policies have been pushed has really
already changed in the the way in every
conference that I go to the dance with
data management these issues of credit
of attribution of data publication keep
coming up and you know new ways of
tracking the citation of the data and
the use of the data so there is a
reaction and I think this will you know
ultimately also get into you know the
promotion procedures and there will be a
new citation index of data and so on but
it's not there yet so and it needs a
push from the science community I think
the science community also needs to get
very engaged in these these discussions
you know this so that it's not only the
data managers who who talk among
themselves about these things and I hope
your prediction will come true because I
sometimes fear that what we are doing is
we are acknowledging this kind of
activity but we are creating a new class
of you know practitioners in academia
rather than saying it's at the same
level as synthesizing data so that's
that's just a note of caution there is a
there are two questions here and then
Bob the citation of data one of the
complaints or concerns that I've heard
express is that somebody who shares
their data and allowing others to use
their data they believe may have may
misuse the data or misinterpret the data
so if the data is cited somebody who
produced that data can search the
literature for others who have used the
data look at their interpretation or use
and be able to comment so it would
generate some discussion about that so I
think that's another added value I mean
again we did just just a brief comment
back to that I think it's in that
respect also very important to have the
data publication go through a certain
process of review in that you want to
make sure that there is appropriate
documentation of the data acquisition
process and so on that certain you know
misuse or misunderstandings about the
data cannot happen so that's you know
again a role of these disciplinary
repositories that can make sure that all
that documentation is included and then
sent the data set on to become
registered and become you know
catalogued someone ok so I'm sayin
leavey i work in with school public
health of town and I'm a Data Manager
for at NIEHS center and a super fun
center and the way we handle data
sharing is a little bit different I'm
wondering what the funding agencies feel
about the way we do it so what we do is
we collect all of the data in sequel
server so you know the data are all in
different structures you know we said we
sit with people before they create their
questionnaires we can help them develop
questionnaires and then we store that we
take their data into sequel server
databases you know the very well
protective off campus and so on but what
we say about sharing is that if people
want our data they can request it and
it's very easy for me to send it Jada's
in a data dictionary and explanation and
my end my time you know how did the
funding agencies react to that as a data
sharing plan rather than putting it out
there in the open because we did try
once where the the NIH mandated for
World Trade Center data that we had
collected that we share it among five
different centers and even though it was
mandated I can't even begin to tell you
how the pushback and they didn't really
send us all of their data and we
couldn't get into any meaningful
organization so that it could just be
searched by anybody who wanted to search
it so it was a quite a process so I'm
just wondering what you think about that
absolutely well again I certainly can't
speak for any funding agency but my
impression is it's so new that I think
that the funding agencies are very open
minded to this and the types of problems
that you might encounter when trying to
share openly or try to sort of share in
a more discreet way and I I mean my
impression is that it's sort of a
wide-open floor now to sort of see what
what works for researchers who are
actually doing this in the field it's
one thing to sit there and you know an
NSF conference room and I wouldn't this
be great it's another thing to gets a
World Trade Center data share it in
collaborations among five institutions
in public access I mean it's a whole
different ballgame so I think the
people's eyes are open and they're
interested in these things I don't think
anyone would be pejorative about what
data researchers are actually doing on
the ground right that's basically and
it's I think there's also an aspect of
resources you know there are a lot of
communities that don't even have any
repository and you know moving from no
repository to something that you know
where at least you can place it
somewhere and you know you can request
data and get it back to having you know
fancy web applications that allow you
our kinds of searches clearly different
levels of investment and communities
need to be willing to invest and support
that so you know if there is a lot of
dissatisfaction for example in your
community I would assume that you know
you could go to NIH and say well we
would like to build something better or
something more sophisticated and then it
can actually happen I
I chance me for an NIH whether that's I
think that's something that you would
have you'd have to make a difficult
argument to NSF for them to actually
fund something like that I think that
would be tough and I have seen are
people who have done a lot of so again I
want to bring this back to software
because it's about software sharing as
well and people who have done a lot of
open source software and coding and
sharing and they would like say NSF
support for their software that's used
in many applications and so on and it
just goes nowhere so I mean the
arguments are still kind of tough in
terms of what level of the funding
agencies willing to support these
infrastructure issues i have heard talk
about a more recent grant funding
initiative at NSF 621 and they're
thinking about maybe you know this is
just my impression but about data
infrastructure as one of the you know
principal interest doctor components
maybe NSF could fund I mean in some
sense NSF funds telescopes why wouldn't
they fund something concrete like didn't
for immunity in some senses and mismatch
there I mean it's one thing if NSF is
going to say well we fund core science
and we don't want to be involved in
long-term you know structural
preservation issues but you know again
they've got a lot of capital investments
already so but but my impression is that
is something that's percolating in
people's minds so this could be
something that we're moving towards and
it's certainly an open question at which
level the do data and code gets to
automate is it at the institutional
level or is it a consortium level or is
this something that a federal agency
would fund and sort of set up like you
searched to the VN NSF cloud I mean
these are sort of open questions that
people are grappling with and also again
it's the problems are so granular that
it becomes a domain-specific question as
well in that respect just to add this I
mean for the earth sciences there's
actually currently a planning effort
going within NSF that is called the
earth cube and is talking about a
hundred million dollars going into
infrastructure for data and software and
computation I mean not the
high-performance computation that
a real significant effort to actually
build an infrastructure yeah i can say
that from from my perspective that there
is a and NSF sometimes actually looks
for ideas that they can fund rather than
being you know hesitant to to put money
into that area i think that there is a
yeah as has been said by by all of you
you know we are in a field of transition
but i personally made the experience
that they are very open to ideas for how
to get data out in a way and content and
preserve them in a way that maximizes
the scientific output from the
investment bomb finally yeah well i mean
unfortunately it's not a linear thing i
mean this is a side in response but in
syed and i were talking about and it's
Apple is going to spend invest 100
million dollars in data net and it's
changed it's mine and it's cut them way
back and you know it's very hard to
figure out and which I guess that's my
question which gets back to the NSF data
management plans which is that you know
NSF actually had a data plan requirement
from a long time and I remember being on
review panels where the reviewers the
panel and the program officers didn't
even notice when it wasn't there or
didn't spend any time it made no
difference in decisions so I mean now
that there's a one or two page plan the
important thing is our reviewers coming
from the community are our panels as
managed by program officers actually
going to take the plan seriously and you
know that includes when somebody budgets
X dollars for for data management that
they take it seriously and don't cut it
when a budget has to be negotiated and
I'm also curious so the the difference
between access and archiving versus
stewardship and curation whether you
have any sense that
NSF is actually if somebody actually
talked about curation they want you know
and wanting to spend time and money on
curation whether that would really be
credible as opposed to yeah I'm making
data available so I'm just curious what
your impressions are of whether NSF and
maybe NIH is experienced in actually
enforcing this policy I mean yeah so I
think one thing that hasn't been clearly
stated but it's worth mentioning is that
each of the directorate's with an NSF
has different policies and requirements
too so just to reinforce that point of
that there really isn't an NSF view I
don't work for NSF either but just
looking at there looking at their
website you can tell obviously different
directors have different views of what
what's happening so with that in mind I
think that again one thing that hasn't
been explicitly stated but I'll say it
is disciplinary or institutional or
other models are complimentary I don't
think they're mutually exclusive or
competitive in some ways Kirsten's
talking about a community that has she
mentioned years of experience and
capacity and knowledge in this area I
think it would be reasonable for that
community come forth and say we'd like
to do curation we'd actually like to
move up that stack to do more
interesting and innovative and useful
things and seems like that's already
started where is it some communities
that they have no tradition of sharing
data they have no existing resources it
would be really hard to say we're going
from zero to a hundred and three seconds
so I think it would have to be tailored
according to each of those communities
in terms of what existing capacity they
have and what science is driven I mean I
think we don't want to lose sight of
that is that ultimately it's about
better science it's not just about
infrastructure so I don't know that
that's a specific answer to your
question let me bring in a question for
that that was posted online and that
thing was by Tiffany Shaw who asked
about archiving output from computer
simulations in her case I think its
atmospheric
insert miss fabric models we in my era
we prod at our probably 10-15 years ago
because we found the state of producers
we actually often need for our
interpretation to see what models are
simulating to reading to a good
interpretation but we never got that
except we found a colleague somewhere
who had the simulation was willing to
share them and since then this
discussion is going on at each big
project design and implementation we
have the same question but I don't think
we have made big progress so what is the
opinion of each of you in your
particular field of expertise about
archiving output from computer
simulation it could be you know related
to science too but but there are
computer simulations everywhere now and
the resistance often comes from those
who do these assimilating or you know we
are doing so many of them we need too
much storage space i mean i think that
should be out of the way right now and
it just seems to be some discomfort to
to make that available is there any way
to encourage that and standardize it so
that we have a little bit more parity
between those who are simulating at
those who are observing i mean i know
that some communities have started to
you know archive and and put models into
repositories I mean systems is when the
earth surface modeling community they
just contacted me actually about
registering models with do is so there's
clearly you know a movement in doing
that and it's probably dependent on what
the community sees as as necessary and
larger effort something like systems
where you want to participate you want
to take advantage of computing
infrastructure and so on if those
communities put up policies and say you
know if you're using our infrastructure
or
Computers instrumentation or whatever
you're gonna have to make those models
available that will drive it forward I'm
not sure about other communities but
that's an example that I know of so some
progress being made in I my sense is my
sense is that this is also highly
community-specific the simulations that
I did as a statistician it would be
enough to share the code right and then
if someone had the code they could get
the output you didn't have to both share
the code and the output I think that if
you have simulations that require you
know hpc to forget the output or they
just take like two months to run or
something then maybe there's an inn or
maybe there's an incentive to put the
output out there as well so that people
can work from what would be your final
data set and perhaps that's what
produced your figures in your paper but
the way I think about reproducible
research is being able to say well
here's where I started with the data the
digital version of the data here's
everything digital I did to it so you do
run into issues where you know there are
long computation times and so on and so
maybe you know there's providing support
for data sets produced part of the way
through is a way to shortcut that that
process so that when you're trying to
verify a colleague's results or another
researchers results you're not you know
sitting there waiting for things to run
or you're not waiting for time on the
Terra grid or something like this but
but again but you know I want to argue
that those I mean maybe I'm wrong on
this but I would argue that those are
not the common cases where we have this
enormous amounts of data and simulation
I think there's tons of simulations that
go on we're sharing the script to
produce the simulation itself is enough
for people to see what you did and
replicate your results yeah I think one
again I don't think we've used this word
yet but I think provenance is a really
important concept in all of this and one
working definition we have very much
resonates with what you just said it's
which people in which machines touch
this data and what did they do with it
and from a preservation perspective
you'd love to get all of that and track
that over time
but from a pragmatic perspective or
maybe even a scientific perspective that
doesn't make sense so really is a
question of the trade-offs between I
think those two views coming together to
what you would hope would be an optimal
balance don't see any questions in your
Derby just oppose one question that that
I sort of had since a long time so the
National Science Foundation other US
agencies are pushing more aggressively
actually than some of our international
partners for data sharing data access
but a lot of projects are becoming
intrinsically international so what does
that actually mean if you are in
programs that are you know where you
have many international partners you are
pushing hard on data access data release
more less real time but then other
countries other funders are not
requiring the same thing so you're
creating a pic radiant and disadvantages
for those who are opening up first did
did you encounter that I mean I'm
looking more from the other scientists
point of view as does casting but is
that something that is common in other
areas too or is that again specific to
our domain so you the idea of data
sharing across international borders not
only are their impacts as you mentioned
about incentives and reward there's also
so I mean I hadn't talked I haven't
talked a lot about intellectual property
issues here but that's another area
where I research in terms of data and
code sharing and the IP issues are
completely different in Europe versus
America and even the sharing protocols
and standards even if we develop them
perfectly here in isolation they don't
translate over so there's also very
practical issues not just cultural
issues or funding issues about how to
actually share or sign up people and
have them on board with with your vision
of how data sharing happens in the
project I I think I think there's an
underlying argument here though that in
a paper that was co-written with my
advisor and a few other people we tried
to make the argument that really the
person who is benefiting from data and
code sharing is the researcher right
from the beginning that they will do
our science and sharing the code in the
data so it's not I think the argument if
you make it to other scientists that
this is good for science it's a very
difficult argument to hear when you have
deadlines on you and people knocking on
your door and you have to do this and so
on but if the argument is really
personal and I did some survey research
about this too it seems to be more
resonant so the idea of doing better
science and des was mentioned earlier
being able to actually access your
previous results and so on and
communicate and your students are able
to come in and work on previous students
work because they've done work that's
reproducible and open and then as Carson
mentioned and there's there's some other
bits of evidence to that you are excited
more and so these benefits kind of come
back to you and so I think that there
are definite perceived disadvantages to
taking the time about data curation or
you know making your code available
ready that you can share it but in in I
think in the long run those will
probably wash out and I wanted to come
back to a point that you mentioned
earlier about the promotion and the
review committees at least from my
perspective it seems to be that
candidates who are coming up to review
now that these things are really
changing and people who are being
discussed for you know jobs or tenure or
whatnot who seemed to be wholly innocent
of these issues of reproducibility and
creation of science seem to be now at a
disadvantage versus others who have
taken proactive steps to ensure
transparency in their work and taken
care over their scientific communication
so I think this is something that we are
starting to see changes that I've been
exposed to so but you know every field
is moving at its own pace and doing it
something definitely true and there are
also different shades of being
transparent of how you grade your
results versus having data out in a
transparent way but not having the time
over that to create synthetic results so
I think that that this is something that
we have to keep keep some some attention
on as we are moving forward EST yeah I
was just adding to that aspect of
international data sharing i think you
know there are clearly and Bob could
comment probably quite a bit on that
from the core data it's a perspective
that there are efforts underway to kind
of make sure that there is more
consistency and common understanding and
I've seen in the last year actually a
proactive engagement internationally the
German Science Foundation coming here to
the US on the specific issue of
scientific data management research data
sharing and so on so I think in many
countries and partly triggered by this
OECD report and so on all nations are
you know moving moving in this direction
of establishing infrastructures and
seeing the the necessity to open an
international dialogue and it's it's
gonna come it's another piece of that
transition period that needs to be
resolved any other questions from the
audience doesn't seem to be the case so
I would like to thank again I was reap
analysts